-Guys, it is time
for "Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-Let's go!
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing
every week
where I send out a hashtag
and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
Thank you all
for playing along.
Spring break is in full swing,
and I sent out a hashtag,
#SpringBreakFail,
and asked you guys to tweet out
your funniest
"spring break gone wrong"
stories.
I sent one out,
but this really happened.
I went to spring break once,
and we got a cab
to go back to our hotel,
and the cab pulled over,
and he goes,
"Hey, do one of you guys
want to drive?
I'm wasted."
[ Laughter ]
It's a true story.
Asked me
if I would drive the cab.
Yeah. We waited for another cab,
I think, or we walked.
I think we could see our hotel.
It was crazy.
And it was within minutes,
it was a trending topic
in the U.S., so thank you
for playing along.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#SpringBreakFail tweets
from you guys.
Here we go. This first one is
from @RainaEatsKale.
-Mm.
-She says...
Oh, there you go.
[ Laughter ]
That's something.
-♪ Ba ba, bwee da ♪
-This one's from
@ItsGivingCaroline.
She says...
There you go. That's fun.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Could've been worse.
-Yeah, come on. Chili's, too.
-Chili's, too, man. I love --
Two nights at Chili's, too?
Uh, this one's from
@SoccerIsLife9999.
-Oh.
-She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪ Ba ba ba, ba ba ♪
♪ Ba ba ba, ba ba ba ba ba ♪
♪ Ba ba ba,
ba ba ba ba ba ♪
♪ Ba ba ba ba ba,
wa-da ♪
♪ Ba ba ba,
bwa-da, bwa-da, ba ♪
♪ Ba ba, bwa-da ♪
♪♪
All right, here go.
-♪ Bwa ba, bwooow ♪
[ Clucks tongue ]
-This next one is from
@sweeptheleg4me.
-Ooh. Cobra Kai.
-They say...
[ Laughter ]
"Are you --"
[ Laughs ]
"Made it to the hotel.
The door's unlocked."
-"Come on, man!
-"Hey, man."
-"Our hotel got smaller."
[ Laughter ]
-"They moved the coffee table
around somewhere."
-"This lobby is super small."
-"Feels like a house."
[ Laughter ]
-"Hey, look at this
refrigerator."
[ Laughter ]
"Wow, there's family pictures."
"Oh, this is very personal."
-"It makes me feel like
I'm at home. I love it."
-[ Snores ]
-"There's a lady sleeping
next to me!
Oh, cool!"
-"Bonus!"
-"Bonus, dude!"
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Ba ba, bwa-da ♪
-This one's from @geoffjeff.
-Ooh, @geoffjeff.
-But it's G-E-O-F-F --
-Oh, so "Joff" Jeff.
-J-E-F --
Oh, "Joff" Jeff.
-Yeah, "Joff" Jeff.
-55.
-Oh, 55.
He can't drive?
-There were 54 other
"Joff" Jeffs.
-"Joff" Jeffs.
[ Laughter ]
-He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's on a raft?
-"Out there somewhere."
This last one's
from @johnathanwickowski4.
Oh, is "Wick" short
for Wickowski?
-Yeah.
-John Wick?
-Oh, maybe.
-John Wickowski.
I didn't know that.
-Don't mess with his puppy.
-@johnathanwickowski4.
Oh, he says...
There you go!
#SpringBreakFail.
That's our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.